you've visited other realms seen
different species aliens have you ever
encountered any that were blue yes of
course
hey youtubers this Charlie this week on
agents of shield
it was totally ladies night roller derby
on a plane jamie alexander guest starred
as SIF and elements a team guest starred
as Lorelai naturally there were a ton of
awesome comic book and movie references
and the blue alien plot really pushed
forward so I'll explain who Lorelai is
real quick and then we could talk about
our top five moments that I'll do my
review and quick shout out I'm doing an
Avengers age of Ultron video later
tonight it's gonna be a breakdown of the
footage we're going to see next week as
part of a special that Marvel is airing
instead of a new episode of agents of
shield that's right we're finally gonna
see actual footage from Avengers age of
Ultron so be sure to subscribe to get
that video so now let's talk about the
weakness and all men Lorelei is played
by illness the teen who you may remember
from Smallville she played Mira wife of
Aquaman in an episode funny to see her
jump to the other team but this is way
better role for her in the comics Loki
used Lorelei to distract Thor while he
was busy trying to build his power this
was back in the 1980s comics the cool
thing is that the story also involves
male cthe the dark elf we saw during the
dark world movie and the fire-god
searcher in the continuity of this
episode she basically been in prison for
the last 600 years presumably captured
by a SIF after the events in the comic
books she escaped during the events of
Thor the dark world you remember when
cursed destroyed the Asgardian prison
that Loki just also happened to be in so
now let's talk about our top five
moments from the episode careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet oh wait just a second
so here we go number 5 what kind of
powers are we talking about so you have
to remember that for most of the shield
agents magic or sorcery or even mutant
based powers don't exist or at least
they don't know about them yet so the
reveal of Lorelei's powers does a couple
really cool things one is just funny to
see all the WTF is Magic faces and it
also opens the door for more strange
powers in the show which i think is just
laying groundwork for the clairvoyant
that is just making whatever strange
powers he or she has seem more plausible
whenever that secret is revealed this
kind of ties into the coming Marvel Age
of miracle
that I'll be talking about during that
Avengers 2 video later tonight number 4
SIF versus the biker gang this is really
the first of many amazing fight scenes
it becomes pretty obvious that the
ladies are going to be having all the
fun this week and I think it's awesome
the biker gang fight was as much
exciting as it was funny
just watching SIF throw them around like
ragdolls and the joke with her pushing
the giant RV with her foot was great
that kind of humor is straight from a
Thor movie just the comedy that comes
from putting a super strong Asgardian in
a fight with regular humans I was really
bummed that SIF didn't get more action
scenes in Thor the dark world and I feel
like this episode kind of rectified that
mistake SIF is such an interesting
character and Jamie Alexander does an
amazing job of playing her I also really
loved that moment when Coulson knew that
she was still hanging on outside the
plank just because she was so tough
number 3
Coulson drills SIF about blue aliens
there was a lot of comic book references
here but SIF lets him note that only one
species actually visited earth the frost
giants a thousand years ago that means
one of three things is possible either a
frost giant was captured or Nick Fury
acquired one from outer space another
alien that is or number-3 my new theory
that Fury captured one that originated
on earth I don't know that he would have
gone into outer space yet even though
guardians of the galaxy is right around
the corner
so the alternate theory to my frost
giant crea REE is now an Atlantean they
have the blue glowy skin and they would
have already been on earth meaning that
the theory fits within the logic that
SIF presented that does kind of dispel
my curry theory but it opens the door to
Skye being part Atlantean if you're not
familiar name war is half at lanten so
he has all these powers and can live
underwater but appears human this is
pretty big so let me know if you agree
with my Skye Atlantean theory in the
comments below
number two SIF versus Lorelei this
wasn't as big a Bal as I expected but I
award bonus points for the creative use
of SIF sword during their duel there
were also some really awesome comic book
references to Lorelei's old plot with
Loki in how she used Thor it's so much
fun to see them bring that comic book
story from the 80s right into the
modern-day Marvel Universe remember as
Guardians lived for about five thousand
years so 602 them is like a decade to us
it would be like the two of them talking
about the war in Iraq
you know something that happened very
recently and my number one moment the
double double-crossed involving Coulson
and Skye on one side and Mei on the
other so many things are connecting
agents of shield to the plot of Winter
Soldier now first let's talk about the
Coulson side of this equation the person
he was talking about tracking down that
person who was responsible is Nick Fury
he's off the grid but we will see him
during Winter Soldier so we probably
won't learn what he's been doing at
least until the last couple of episodes
or maybe not even till the movie
premieres then let's flip to the other
side with me she's been keeping tabs on
Coulson for someone else I'm betting
that it's Robert Redford's character
he'd be one of the few people with
security clearance and power inside of
shield to know all about that blue alien
but now it's your turn let me know what
was your favorite moment from the
episode you know was it the blue alien
plot was it the roller derby on a plane
all the fight scenes or was it just
seeing SIF and Lorelei overall I gave
the episode an a just for amazing use of
a movie character Jamie Alexander and a
comic book character Lorelei I hope we
get to see her in another Marvel movie
Lorelei that is more back on the show
next season Jamie Alexander got way more
screen time that she did in any of the
Thor movies too and I hope they really
expand her role for Thor 3 her character
deserves way more screen time than
Natalie Portman and if rumors are to be
believed that won't be an issue
I'm saying Portman might not return for
that third movie I don't know what her
contract says though so I can't confirm
that
Ellen astatine was also so much more fun
than any of the other guest stars this
season it's like the Tom Hilson Loki
bonus that characters get the actors
playing villains get to have way more
fun and be way more complex than any of
the heroes not to say the SIF is not
also a ton of fun - the only thing I
thought could have been done better was
the men versus women plot the gender
humor I understand that it's a slam dunk
to do gender humor like this whenever
the villains powers are all about
manipulating men and the jokes were
totally funny - but I didn't think it
was totally necessary so think about it
the other way you don't need to show
women as being weak to make men seem
strong so the opposite has to be true as
well I don't think he need a bunch of
weak men in a Wonder Woman movie just to
make her seem more powerful just like
you don't need to show a bunch of weak
women to make Superman seem powerful
that being said Fitz was so much fun to
watch being drunk in love with Lorelei
and watching Simmons almost cracked
Colson with that fire extinguisher it's
too bad shield can't be this funny all
the time but sometimes you know having
super-strength and a bunch of Asgardians
makes it a lot easier there was one more
big question that I had after the
episode and it ties into Thor the dark
world in the rest of the movies it has
to do with sifts mission she was ordered
by Odin to bring Lorelei back to Asgard
but when you remember the ending of Thor
the dark world and consider that it
probably happened before the events of
this episode it makes you wonder was it
really lucky giving her those orders as
Odin or was it Odin himself that remains
to be answered but it does offer a lot
of places for where Lorelei's character
can go next from here so in related news
remember I'm posting that Avengers 2
video later tonight you can click here
to watch that I'll add the annotation as
soon as I post it and you can click here
to learn about all my alternate sky
mists Marvel theories remember that is
expanded now to include Atlantean
theories based on this episode thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you